So now, we know the toolbox provided
by SPIN for building an operating system. Now,
one can build each of the services we talked about early on, that an operating
system should provide. Such as memory management,
CPU scheduling, threads, file system, network protocol stack,
and so on, from scratch, as extensions
to SPIN. As we know, memory management and
CPU scheduling are core services that
any operating system should provide. However,
an extensible operating system should not
dictate how these services should be implemented.
SPIN provides interface procedures for implementing
these services in the operating system.
Physical memory is a precious resource.
We know that native operating systems such
as Linux or Windows manages the physical memory that is available from the
hardware. SPIN wants to allow extensions to manage physical memory allocated to
them in whatever fashion they choose to. The macro-allocation of a bunch
of physical memory to an extension, it's outside the scope of this discussion.
But, assume that the allocation of a bunch of physical memory happens when an
extension's charged up. The discussion in this tablet frame is to do with the
management of the pre-allocated physical memory by
the extension. The interface functions that I'm
showing you here from memory management are
simply header files provided by SPIN. For example,
allocating a page frame. Deallocating a page frame. Reclaiming
a page frame. Similarly, allocating a virtual page or
deallocating a virtual page which might be used for dynamic memory allocation.
Translating, has to do with creating and destroying address
spaces, adding or removing mapping between virtual
pages, and physical frames. All of those
are interface functions, that are provided as header
files by SPIN. And memory management, because of
what we said earlier about overcommitment of memory.
Not all of a processor's address space
is going to be fitting in physical memory.
So, there are event handlers, that are provided
as part of the core service of SPIN
for handling page fault, access fault, meaning, if you had
a page that is write protected and if a process tries to write to it, that's an
access violation. Or, if a process is trying to access a region of
memory that it doesn't have access to, generating a bad
address exception. All of these are interface functions that
are defined as core services of memory
management in the SPIN operation system. It
is not saying anything about how these
services are implemented, but it is giving you
just a header file. The implementer of an extension has to write the actual
code for these header functions and create
a logical protection domain that corresponds to physical
address management, virtual address management, translation
management, and the handler functions for
dealing with these different types of
events. Once the logical protection domain is
dynamically instantiated, it becomes an extension
of SPIN, and after that there's
no border crossing between a particular
service that has been so instantiated and
SPIN itself. And all of these
functions are invoked automatically when the hardware
events occur, corresponding to a page fault or access violation fault and so on.